meine Lieben visualpolitik Zuschauer wir
haben eine sehr schlechte Nachricht für
euch der dihadismus befindet sich auf
dem
Vormarsch zumindest waren viele Experten
sowohl in Europa als auch den USA dass
diese gewaltige religiöse Lawine immer
größer wird die große Mehrheit der
Analysten behauptet dass die Ausbreitung
des Islam mittels Gewalt einen neuen
Boom erlebt und was ist der jüngste
Auslöser ihr könnt es sicher schon
erraten wir sprechen von der
brandgefährlichen Situation die die
Hamas mit dem Angriff auf Israel
entzündet hat und einige werden sich nun
fragen aber war der dihadistische
Terrorismus nicht eigentlich dabei sich
zurückzuziehen ja zu verschwinden nun ja
nichts könnte weiter von der Wahrheit
entfernt sein wenn ihr treue Anhänger
von visualpolitik seid werdet ihr euch
erinnern dass in Ländern wie Pakistan
Afghanistan und Usbekistan Anschläge an
der Tagesordnung sind und vergesst bitte
nicht Afrika die die Sahelzone ist von
jihadistischen Terroristen geradezu
verseucht Mali Burkina Faso Niger und so
weiter und so fort sogar china hat trotz
rabiater und kompromissloser
Unterdrückungsmaßnahmen immer mehr
Probleme es gibt jedoch einen erteil bei
dem man wahrlich von einem echten
Comeback reden kann und wo genau erlebt
der islamische Djihad sein größtes
Comeback ganz genau vor allem in Europa
seit dem Angriff der Hamas auf Israel
und der israelischen Gegenoffensive in
Gaza stoßen wir immer wieder auf
Nachrichten wie die folgenden und glaub
mir es handelt sich wahrlich nicht um
Bagatellen das Problem der
antisemitischen Gewalt ist massiv schon
vor dem 7 Oktober war es Realität in
Städten wie Berlin duusburg oder Bochum
dass als Juden erkennbare Menschen
Gefahr liefen auf der Straße beschimpft
bespuckt oder attackiert zu werden man
muss es klar sagen es gibt für Juden
NoGo areas in Deutschland zahlreiche
Viertel in vielen Städten sind für Juden
nicht mehr sicher wenn es um Terror geht
ist der Rechtsextremismus ganz klar die
größere Gefahr die alltäglichen verbalen
und körperlichen Übergriffe kommen
allerdings nach Wahrnehmung vieler Juden
größtenteils aus dem muslimisch
geprägten Milieu Frankreich fürchtet
dass die Terroristen ihr eigentliches
Ziel erreichen in Paris wird ein
deutscher erstochen von einem
islamistischen Attentäter viele
Franzosen haben sich an solche
Einzeltaten schon gewöhnt aber Experten
warnen sie seinen oft Vorboten großer
organisierter Anschläge auf seiner
Flucht soll der Täter zwei weitere
Personen mit einem Hammer attackiert und
einen englischen Touristen dabei schwer
im Auge verletzt haben der Polizei
gelang es mit einem Taser die Kontrolle
über den Täter zu gewinnen der die
Polizisten bedrohte und dabei allahu
akbar Gott es groß gerufen haben soll
die antiterrorstaatsanwaltschaft
ermittelt gegen den 1997 in Frankreich
geborenen armont RM wegen Mordes und
versuchten Mordes bei seiner Verhaftung
habe er die Tat mit den Worten begründet
er halte nicht mehr aus dass Muslime in
Afghanistan und Palästina sterben in
einem Video bekannte sich der Täter zur
jihadistenmiliz is Alarm in Italien
verstärkte Überwachung an Orten die mit
der jüd Gemeinde in Verbindung stehen
Schweden erhöht nach Koranverbrennungen
die Terrorwarnstufe Dänemark und
Schweden haben die Grenzkontrollen
verschärft da sie Anschläge mit hoher
Bedrohung befürchten vor etwas mehr als
10 Jahren hatten wir in Europa bereit
die Erfahrung gemacht wie es ist alle
paar Jahre ein jihadistischen Anschlag
zu erleiden am Ende verlor das Phänomen
aber immer mehr an Kraft bis die
covid-pandemie es schließlich quasi
platt machte allerdings könnte diese
Zeit der relativen Ruhe nun vorbei sein
analysten warnen bereits von neuen
Formen die der dihadistische Terrorismus
in den letzten Jahren angenommen hat
Formen die noch schwerer fassbar sind
und erfolgreicher als in der
Vergangenheit und genau aus diesem Grund
haben wir uns hier bei visualpolitik ein
paar Fragen gestellt wie ist es Europa
eigentlich gelungen die Welle des
jihadismus zu bekämpfen die den
Kontinent vor ein paar Jahren
heimgesucht hat stehen wir wirklich vor
einer neuen noch größeren Welle des
jihadistischen Terrorismus warum könnten
neue Formen des jihadismus eine viel
größere Gefahr für Europa darstellen als
frühere in diesem Video werden wir
natürlich all diese wichtigen Fragen
vollumfänglich beantworten lasst mich
euch aber vorher noch eine andere
wichtige Frage stellen hättest du nicht
auch Lust in 20 Minuten einfach mal
schnell
1095 € einzustreichen tja dann ist heute
eventuell dein Glückstag hör zu das
heutige Video hat nämlich unser Sponsor
steuerbot möglich gemacht das ist eine
äußerst praktische App mit der du deine
Steuererklärung ganz easy am Handy bin
20 Minuten erledigen kannst denn WUs du
dass viele deutsche Steuerzahler jedes
Jahr viel Geld verschenken nur weil sie
durch die komplexe steuerbürokratie
abgeschrckt werden dabei würde es sich
durchaus lohen sich mal zu überwinden
schließlich haben laut statistischenem
Bundesamt im vergangenen Jahr 12,3
Millionen Menschen eine Steuererstattung
bekommen und zwar im Schnitt eben jene
1095 €. und das beste mit steuerbot muss
man sich noch nicht einmal überwinden um
die Steuererstattung einstreichen zu
können steuerbard ist nämlich quasi so
etwas wie chetgpt mit einem
Steuerberatung Plugin das während es mit
Dir ganz easy plaudert im Hintergrund
schon mal deine Steuererklärung ausfüllt
und optimiert innerhalb von 20 Minuten
ist die Steuererklärung fertig und zur
Übermittlung ans Finanzamt bereit
komplett papierlos und digital
selbstverständlich übernimmt Steuerbord
auch die Übermittlung du musst dich noch
nicht mal mit dem Finanzamt
auseinandersetzen alles was du brauchst
ist deine Lohnsteuerbescheinigung mehr
nicht und sollte es notwendig sein
unterstützt dich auch der fachkundige
menschliche Support jederzeit mit
garantierten Antwortzeiten innerhalb von
24 Stunden übrigens dein
Steuererstattungsanspruch kannst du über
steuerbard vorab komplett gratis prüfen
du kannst deine Steuererklärung
kostenlos eingeben und anhand der
berechneten Rückerstattung dann
entscheiden ob es sich für dich lohnt
also schenkt dem stat nicht mehr euer
sauer verdientes Geld und klickt auf den
Link oder Scann den QR-Code auf dem
Bildschirm denn mit dem Gutscheincode
visual bekommst du noch mal 10 € Rabatt
du deinem Geldbeutel etwas Gutes und
fang jetzt gleich an so einfach steuern
zu sparen wie nie zuvor und vielleicht
kommt dabei ja genug um dass du damit
auch unsere Arbeit finanziell
unterstützen kannst den Spendenlink dazu
findest du übrigens ebenfalls in der
Beschreibung unter dem
[Musik]
Video Europa im Angesicht des
Terrors wusstet ihr eigentlich dass der
jihadistische Terrorismus in Europa fast
alle überrascht hat der alte Kontinent
war an eine andere Art von Terrorismus
gewöhnt an eine nationalistische und
politische wie die der in Spanien der
IRA in Großbritannien und der RAF in
Deutschland die Wahrheit ist allerdings
dass die Überraschung der Europäer
keineswegs gerechtfertigt war einige
jihadistische Kämpfer hatten bereits in
den 1980er Jahren begonnen auf den alten
Kontinent vorzudringen und es dauerte
nicht lange bis sie begann die
europäischen Stützpunkte und Strukturen
größer Netzwerke wie z.B der algerischen
radikalislamischen Gruppe oder al-qida
zu errichten auf diese Weise wurde
Europa zu einem wichtigen dihadistischen
Nest
ursprünglich waren diese Netzwerke die
hauptsächlich von al-Qaida angeführt
wurden hierarchisch organisiert doch
nach den Anschlägen vom 11 September in
New York beschloss Osama bin Laden diese
Struktur komplett zu ändern angesichts
der terrorismusbekämpfungsstrategie der
USA die darauf abzielte die Anführer der
Organisation und des globalen jihadismus
auszuschalten wurden die Netzwerke
dezentralisiert die Idee dahinter selbst
wenn binladen und die anderen
redelsführer ausgestaltet würden könnte
der globale jihadismus trotzdem
problemlos weiter funktionieren außerdem
wäre es viel schwieriger ihn zu
verfolgen und zu bekämpfen infolgedessen
kam es in Europa zu einer deutlichen
Zunahme von antiterroroperation bei
denen einige Zellen ausgehoben wurden im
Januar 2003 wurden z.B zwei kleine
jihadistische Zellen in Italien
ausgehoben in Spanien fand im selben
Jahr die berühmte Operation Lago an
mehren Orten in Katalonien statt die zur
Zerschlagung einer mittelgroßen
algerischen Zelle führte aber als die
dezentralisierungsstrategie dann
umgesetzt wurde wurde alles noch viel
komplizierter
Europa hatte sich kein bisschen
vorbereitet auf das was dann kommen
sollte am 11 märz 2004 verübte eine
jihadistische Zelle einen brutalen
Anschlag in Spaniens Hauptstadt Madrid
mit zehn Bomben die in verschiedenen
Bereichen öffentlicher Verkehrsmittel
platziert waren wurden bei dem Anschlag
193 Menschen getötet und mehr als 2000
verletzt es handelte sich um den
zweitgrößten Terroranschlag in der
Geschichte des
Kontinents wie euch vorstellen könnt war
dies ein Wendepunkt in der Wahrnehmung
des radikalislamischen und
jihadistischen Terrorismus in Europa die
Besorgnis der Europäer über dieses Thema
erreichte ein historisch hohes Niveau
das nach dem Bombenanschlag auf die
Londoner U-Bahn im darauffolgenden Jahr
2005 noch weiter zunahm bei diesem
wurden weitere 50 Menschen getötet und
etwa 700 verletzt seitdem befindet sich
Europa in höchster Alarmbereitschaft auf
dem alten Kontinent wurden einige
kleinere Anschläge verübt und einige
größere vereitelt wiederanschlag den 14
Jihadisten mit Verbindungen zu al-Qaida
in in der U-Bahn von Barcelona im Januar
2008 geplant hatten allerdings gab es
2014 dann Nachrichten die die
dihadistischen Aktivitäten in Europa auf
ein noch nie daagewesenes Niveau anheben
sollten Isis Rebellen rufen islamischen
Staat in Irak und Syrien aus in der Tat
rief daesch bzw Isis den sogenannten
islamischen Staat aus und der globale
jihadismus erreichte seinen Höhepunkt
der jihadistische Terrorismus breitete
sich auf der ganzen Welt aus und Europa
traf er besonders hart es begann die
erste jihadistische Welle die Europa als
solche erlebt
hat die Zahl der Anschläge in den
Ländern der Europäischen Union sind
damals stark gestiegen und mit ihnen
auch die der Todesopfer 347 allein
zwischen 2015 und 2017 86 davon allein
bei dem brutalen Anschlag in Nizza 2016
und es geht nicht nur um Opfer nach und
nach schürten diese Anschläge ein
allgemeines Gefühl der Angst und dennoch
begann die jihadistische Bedrohung in
Europa durch die fortschreitende
Schwächung von daesch ab 2017 und die
gemeinsamen und individuellen Bemühungen
der europäischen Länder stark zu sinken
um euch einen Eindruck zu verschaffen im
Jahr 2022 gab es dann nur sechs
Anschläge doch nun hatte Angriff der
Hamas auf Israel und die israelische
Reaktion insbesondere im Gazastreifen
die Spannungen in der weltweiten
muslimischen Gemeinschaft auf einen
Höhepunkt gebracht der ehemalige
hamasführer Khalid mesaal ging sogar s
weit in einem Werbespot aufzutreten den
viele Analysten als Aufruf zum globalen
dihad interpretierten an alle Gelehrten
die den dihad um Gottes Willen Lehren
und die Kämpfer und mertürer predigen an
alle die Lehren und Lernen dies ist ein
Moment der Anwendung der Theorien damit
Worte nicht nur Worte sind infolgessen
haben sowohl die Regierung Europas als
auch der USA vor einem möglichen neuen
Anstieg des jihadistischen Terrorismus
gewarnt aber handelt es sich wirklich um
einen Aufruf zum globalen Jihad sollten
es nicht Organisationen wie al-Qaida
oder da sein die so etwas tun nun nehmen
wir doch mal lieber etwas genauer unter
die Lupe was wirklich dahinter steckt
aufgepasst das Comeback des globalen
Jihad am 7 Oktober 2023 verübte die
Hamas den blutigsten Terroranschlag in
der Geschichte Israels mehr als 1400
Menschen wurden getötet darunter Kinder
Frauen und ältere Menschen die Bilder
schockierten die ganze Welt viele
verglichen sie mit der härtesten era von
daesh darunter auch der israelische
Premierminister Benjamin Netanyahu die
Hamas hat Kinder gefesselt verbrannt und
hingerichtet das sind wilde die Hamas
ist Isis und so wie sich die Kräfte der
Zivilisation zusammenschlossen um Isis
zu besiegen müssen die Kräfte der
Zivilisation Israel dabei unterstützen
die Hamas zu besiegen seitdem rollt die
israelische Gegenoffensive die idfs sind
in den Gazastreifen eingedrungen und
haben hundert und tausende von Zielen
bombardiert es ist ihn außerdem gelungen
tausende von von hamasterroristen zu
liquidieren die von der Hamas natürlich
wie üblich als Zivilisten oder sogar als
Kinder ausgegeben werden mit Hilfe
dieser propagand Lügen versucht die
chamas sowohl die weltweite
Öffentlichkeit als auch die muslimische
Gemeinschaft aufzupeitschen das hat
sogar dazu geführt dass die militärische
verteidigungsaktion Israels als
Völkermord bezeichnet wird und nun
befürchtet die große Mehrheit Analysten
dass dies den perfekten Vorwand für
einen massenaufruf zum Jihad darstellt
dazu passt natürlich sehr gut die
Botschaft des ehemaligen Kamas Hörers
und viele behaupten gar dass der
hamasanschlag genau das im Sinn hatte
aber haben Mesa als Worte überhaupt
irgend eine Bedeutung nun einerseits ja
andererseits aber auch nein was ich
damit meine nun al-qida und daesh die
ultimativen Vertreter des globalen
jihadismus lieben die Hamas in etwa so
sehr wie ein Moslem Schweinespeck liebt
mit anderen Worten gar nicht ja es
stimmt kamamas al-Qaida und daes sind
sich in bestimmten Punkten durchaus
einig ihr Hass auf Israel ihre
Wahrnehmung des Hebräischen Landes
wahlweise als Marionette des Westens
oder dessen Strippenzieher und die
Förderung von Gewalt gegen die jüdische
Gemeinschaft außerdem lehnen sie auch
alles ab was mit Freiheit
Gleichberechtigung Demokratie und
Aufklärung zu tun hat und bekämpfen
diese Werte auch aktiv überall wo es
geht aber andererseits sind sie eben
auch starke Konkurrenten und die
Beziehungen zwischen ihnen sind ziemlich
[Musik]
mies
seit der Teilnahme der Hamas an den
Wahlen zum palästinensischen
legislativrat im Jahr 2006 haben sowohl
al-Qaida als auch daesh diese
palästinensische Organisation scharf
kritisiert die beiden führenden
Vertreter des globalen jihadismus
verurteilten die Teilnahme der Hamas an
einem demokratischen Prozess den beide
als unrein bezeichneten natürlich hat
die Hamas die Demokratie damals auch nur
missbraucht um an die Macht zu kommen
und sie dann abzuschaffen aber die
relative Langsamkeit und das zu
zögerliche Vorgehen der Hamas bei der
Durchsetzung der Sharia im Gazastreifen
wird von den beiden anderen
Terrorgruppen kritisiert außerdem hat
die Annäherung der Hamas an den Iran und
die hisisballa nicht gerade dazu
beigetragen ihre Beziehungen wieder
aufzubauen tatsächlich geht vor allem
daesch besonders hart gegen die Hamas
und ihren Unterstützer Iran vor da sie
sie dafür kritisiert dass sie nicht die
Errichtung eines globalen islamischen
Staates zum Ziel haben sondern nur die
Befreiung Palästinas in den Vordergrund
stellen der islamische Staat bekennt
sich zu Bombenanschlägen im Iran mehr
als 80 Menschen wurden bei der Explosion
während einer Zeremonie zum Tod des
iranischen Generals Kassem Soleimani
getötet und zahlreiche weitere verletzt
al-Qaida wiederum unterscheidet zwischen
dem politischen Arm der Hamas den sie
scharf verurteilt und ihre militärischen
Arm den kassambrigaden die sie
[Musik]
unterstützt aber so sehr die Hamas auch
zum globalen Jihad aufrufen mag wenn
seine beiden Hauptvertreter sie nicht
unterstützen ist es unwahrscheinlich
dass er stattfinden wird und die Frage
lautet haben sowohl al-Qaida als auch
daesh zum globalen Jihad aufgerufen nun
nicht ganz aber sie sind dem ziemlich
nah
gekommen ihr müsst nämlich verstehen
dass es für den Angriff der Hamas
seitens al-Qaida ziemlich großen Applaus
gab al-Qaida nutzte nämlich die
Gelegenheit um zu Angriffen auf
amerikanische Ziele im Nahen Osten
aufzurufen insbesondere in den großen
Städten der Länder die das Abraham
Abkommen unterzeichnet haben al-Qaida
liegt in dieser Angelegenheit also auf
einer Linie mit dem Iran daesh
seinerseits gratulierte der Hamas nie
und kritisierte sie weiterhin für ihre
Verbindungen zum Iran sie nutzten
allerdings die Gelegenheit eine Liste
mit jüdischen Zielen zu veröffentlichen
die überall auf der Welt angegriffen
werden sollen und es ist ziemlich
unerheblich ob es sich dabei wirklich um
einen formellen Aufruf zum globalen
Jihad handelt oder nicht es handelt sich
um einen Aufruf zu gezielter Gewalt und
wisst ihr was er hat bereits
Auswirkungen gehabt und hat sie noch
immer Ägypten Polizist erschießt zwei
israelische Touristen und einen
ägyptischen Reiseführer ein Mitarbeiter
der israelischen Botschaft in China
wurde erstochen ein ausländischer
Verdächtiger wird
festgenommen 16 Oktober 2023 Schießerei
in Brüssel Europa erschüttert nachdem
zwei Schweden erschossen wurden und das
meine Lieben Zuschauer sind nur drei
Beispiele leider Schein die Berichte
über judenfeindliche Taten und
Terroranschläge zuzunehmen und es
überrascht nicht dass sie auch Europa
erreicht haben dabei ist das Problem auf
dem alten Kontinent vielleicht sogar
noch größer als im Rest des Westens
warum dem so ist nun hört jetzt genau
hin der alglatte
jihadismus seit der intensiven
Reaktivierung des Konflikts zwischen der
Hamas und Israel nehmen die Anschläge
islamischer radikaler wieder wöchentlich
Platz in den internationalen Nachrichten
ein Ägypten und China waren unter den
ersten aber Europa ist leider nicht
zurückgeblieben 13 Oktober 2023 Lehrer
getötet und zwei Verletzte bei
Messerstecherei in Schule in
Nordfrankreich 25 Oktober 2023
Deutschland verhaftte Islamist der einen
anti-israelischen Terroranschlag plante
ein Mann der zuvor wegen sein
Mitgliedschaft im sogenannten
islamischen Staat verurteilt worden war
wurde festgenommen nach Angaben der
Staatsanwaltschaft plante er angeblich
ein Islam motivierten Anschlag auf eine
proisrael Demonstration alle gaben an im
Auftrag von daesch also dem islamischen
Staat zu handeln und einer von ihnen
hatte bereits enge Verbindungen zu
dieser internationalen Terrorgruppe
allerdings offenbaren diese Fälle etwas
viel wichtigeres das neue Gesicht des
jihadistischen Terrorismus das Europa
seit dem Aufstieg von daes beherrscht
die Rede ist von der Figur des einsamen
[Musik]
Wolfs der einsame Wolf das heßt eine
Person die sich eigenständig
radikalisiert hat und keinen oder nur
begrenzten Kontakt zu terroristischen
Zellen hatte war in erster Linie für
Terroranschläge in Europa verantwortlich
so wurden z.B zwischen 2014 und 2017 den
Jahren in denen der jihadismus auf dem
Kontinent Anstieg 85% aller Anschläge
von einsamen Wölfen verübt derzeit
stellen diese Terroristen die größte
Bedrohung für Europa da und zwar aus
zwei Gründen erstens weil ihr Kontakt zu
Terrorzellen manchmal gleich null ist
und sich ihre Entdeckung daher viel
schwieriger gestaltet und zweitens weil
sie mit alltäglichen Werkzeugen
angreifen können die keinen Verdacht
erregen wie z.B mit Messern zweifellos
bereiten Sie den westlichen
Sicherheitsbehörden großes
Kopfzerbrechen denn sie haben quasi ihre
Schwachstelle geknackt mit diesen neuen
Akteuren die potenziell gefährlicher
sind als die alten Terrorzellen die
Europa zu Beginn des Jahrhunderts
angegriffen haben ist nicht zu spaßen um
euch eine Vorstellung zu geben allein in
Spanien werden derzeit mindestens 300
potenzielle einsame Wölfe verfolgt und
die Tendenz ist Star stark steigend das
rekrutierungspotenzial geht in die
Tausende aus diesem Grund versuchen die
europäischen geheimdienst- und
Sicherheitsbehörden seit einiger Zeit
dieses Phänomen in einem der Bereiche zu
bekämpfen der die meisten einsamen Wölfe
hervorgebracht hat soziale Medien und
virtuelle
Räume ihr müsst nämlich verstehen dass
das daesh also eisiskifat zwar physisch
fast vollständig verschwunden ist seine
virtuelle Präsenz aber nie nachgelassen
hat während der lockdowns der ersten
covidwelle wurde seine Präsenz sogar
noch stärker und damit auch die Online
Rekrutierung dies ist besonders
besorgniserregend da einsame Wölfe oft
von verschiedenen anwerbern und
virtuellen Trainern lernen wie man
Sprengsätze zusammenbaut das war z.B der
Fall beim Bombenleger von Manchester im
Jahr 2017 und auf der anderen Seite hat
sich die Online Propaganda des
jihadismus so einfach sie auch sein mag
als ungeheuer effektiv erwiesen und zwar
indem sie die starke
identitätsverwirrung vieler musoslims
der zweiten oder dritten
einwandergeneration in europäischen länd
dann ausnutzen sie impfen ihn ein Gefühl
der Opferrolle gegenüber den
vermeintlichen Aggression des Westens
und seiner Gesellschaften ein mit dieser
Methode haben die Anwerber des globalen
jihadismus immer mehr Anhänger und damit
potenzielle Terroristen
gewonnen ihr rekrutierungspool geht
theoretisch in die Millionen außerdem
weisen viele Analysten auf eine andere
Quelle hin die ein potenzielles Nest für
dsihadisten darstellt Gefängnisse
tatsächlich würde mchen Musch der 2014
für den Bombenanschlag auf ein jüdisches
Museum in Belgien verantwortlich war
während seiner fünfjährigen Haftstrafe
wegen Raubüberfalls radikalisiert ihr
müsst nämlich verstehen dass wir heute
in europäischen Gefängnissen hunderte
wenn ich tausende von ehemaligen daesh
Kämpfern finden die den alten Kontinent
verlassen haben um im Irak und in Syrien
zu kämpfen wir dürfen nicht vergessen
dass mehr als 6000 von ihnen mit
europäischen Pässen dorthinegangen sind
Analysten und nationale
Sicherheitsberater befürchten daher dass
sie andere Gefängnisinsassen
radikalisieren und die gefängn zu
potentiellen Jihadisten Trainingslagern
machen um dem entgegen zuwiken müsste
man die daeschhäftlinge isolieren das
heißt wieder spezielle
terroristengefängnisse errichten wie
zuur Zeiten der RAF und als ob das noch
nicht genug wäre gibt es auch noch
Warnungen vor der Freilassung ehemaliger
europäischer daeschterroristen viele
haben ihre Strafen nämlich bereits
verbüst und zum Zeitpunkt der Entlassung
ist nicht genau bekannt auf welchem
radikalisierungsniveau sie sich
überhaupt befinden und das alles
bedeutet nur eines nämlich dass Europa
vor einer neuen Welle des
dsihadistischen Terrorismus zu stehen
scheint ihr seht also dass Risiko liegt
definitiv auf dem Tisch die muslimische
Gemeinschaft ist weltweit in Aufruhr und
die radikale Botschaft die von al-Qaida
und daesch verbreitet wird hat bereits
einen kleinen aber absolut
problematischen Teil dieser Gemeinschaft
durchdrungen Europa hat die erste Welle
des jihadistischen Terrorismus vor
weniger als einem Jahrzehnt überstanden
aber heute könnten die einsamen Wölfe
für eine neue era des Terrors sorgen
ihre größere Vielseitigkeit macht es
viel schwieriger die potentielle neue
dihadistische Welle in Europa
einzudämmen und den Geheimdiensten und
Sicherheitsbehörden bleibt nichts
anderes übrig als ihre Strategien zur
Terrorismusbekämpfung vollkommen neu zu
gestalten denn tun sie es nicht wird
auch Europa durch diese gewalttätige
sperspitze des islamischen
Expansionismus und Kolonialismus
zermürbt werden so wie viele andere
Länder und Kulturen in der Geschichte
zuvor aber jetzt sind die Fragen an Euch
gerichtet glaubt ihr dass Europa
wirklich eine neue große Welle von
Jihadisten droht wie könnte es eurer
Meinung nach mit der Herausforderung der
einsamen Wölfe umgehen denkt ihr dass
Sicherheitsbehörden und Regierung dieses
Übel in eurem Land wirklich an der
Wurzel bekämpfen und nicht nur Symptome
welche Maßnahmen müssen die europäischen
Länder eurer Meinung nach ergreifen
damit sie nicht so enden wie z.B der
Libanon wie immer sind auf eure
Diskussionsbeiträge zu diesem heißen
Thema schon mächtig gespannt ich hoffe
dass euch dieses Video trotz des
deprimier Themas gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht auch etwas dabei gelernt habt
was ja gibt uns bitte ein Like teilt mit
euren Freunden und auf den sozialen
Medien und diskutiert es dort natürlich
freuen wir uns auch jederzeit über eine
Spende von euch mit uns helf dieses
Projekt weiterzuführen den Link dazu
findet ihr in der Beschreibung un dem
Video macht's gut und bis
[Musik]
bald